Musique dynamique
...
-Je suis
comme beaucoup de gens
du secteur,
on est désolés,
pas catastrophés,
mais pas loin.
-Ca fait 10 ans
que je suis sur Hillion.
C'est vrai que j'ai pas vu
beaucoup d'évolution.
-A chaque fois que je sens
la mauvaise odeur,
je me dis
que c'est les algues vertes.
-Là, ça vient, avec le vent.
-Vous sentez quoi ?
-Ben, c'est comme...
l'odeur de la mer,
mais pourrie.
-Quand je veux aller
sur une plage...
Ca m'est arrivé de vouloir
y aller avec mon chien,
j'arrivais devant la plage,
elle était fermée.
-Tout ça, ça vient
des élevages intensifs.
Voilà. Que peut-on faire
contre ce phénomène ?
...
-Bonjour.
Je suis Mickaël Cosson,
député MoDem
de la circonscription
de Saint-Brieuc.
On a un fléau qui dure
depuis plusieurs décennies :
les algues vertes.
Un travail doit être fait
en amont pour les diminuer,
mais aussi en aval
pour faire en sorte
qu'on les ramasse
avant qu'elles s'échouent.
Objectif : que nos plages
ne soient plus fermées.
-Un tapis vert
qui recouvre les plages
tout le long de la côte.
Chaque année,
au début de l'été,
c'est le même spectacle.
Mickaël Cosson y est habitué.
La ville de Hillion,
dont il a été maire neuf ans,
est au fond de la baie
de Saint-Brieuc,
qui concentre 60 %
des algues vertes de Bretagne.
Des algues nocives
qui, souvent, condamnent
les plages du littoral.
-La première plage
que j'ai fermée,
c'était celle-ci.
De souvenir,
c'était en 2017.
J'ai été amené à la refermer
en 2019, en 2021, en 2022,
et cette année, en 2023,
elle est à nouveau fermée.
-La plage de l'Hôtellerie
est interdite d'accès
depuis début juin.
Exceptionnellement, le député
accepte de nous y emmener.
-Là, typiquement,
vous avez des algues vertes
qui viennent s'échouer.
Le sol n'est pas assez meuble
pour pouvoir avoir
des remorques
qui viennent sur cet espace,
parce que c'est un milieu
plutôt vaseux et rocheux.
-Nous ne resterons
que sur la partie sablonneuse,
et pas trop longtemps.
Une odeur nauséabonde
envahit l'air.
-Vous sentez un peu
cette odeur d'oeuf pourri.
C'est l'odeur caractéristique
du H2S.
-H2S pour hydrogène sulfuré.
Un gaz toxique
qui se dégage quand les algues
se décomposent.
Il peut être dangereux
pour la santé,
et à haute dose, mortel.
-Au milieu, là,
il y a une nappe
qui commence à blanchir.
Elle entre en putréfaction.
Si elle a une épaisseur
suffisamment importante,
c'est là qu'on peut avoir
des poches de H2S
qui peuvent se développer
en interne,
et dès lors que
vous êtes amené à marcher,
vous risquez
d'avoir un malaise,
voire plus.
-Alors, sur le sable,
c'est souvent
une course contre la montre
pour retirer les algues.
La municipalité a 48 heures
après échouage
pour les ramasser
avant qu'elles n'entrent
en putréfaction.
-Salut, Thomas.
Ca va ?
-Ca va.
-Je vois que le sable...
-Un agglo à ramasser.
-Là, ils reviennent ?
-Eh ben... Je sais pas trop,
s'ils ont ramassé ce matin,
s'ils reviennent
cet après-midi.
-L'ancien maire devenu député
assiste à ce ballet de tracteurs
depuis des années.
Bips du tracteur
-Le tracteur ramasse,
sur les zones sur lesquelles
il peut aller,
les algues fraîches
qui se sont échouées
après le retrait de la mer.
Là, ça fonctionne parfaitement,
le sol est bien meuble.
Derrière, ça s'enfonce pas.
Il peut ainsi,
en quelques minutes,
ramasser ce qui s'est échoué.
Par contre, il est tenu
dans un périmètre
entre des vasières
et des rochers.
-10 % des côtes seulement
sont accessibles
aux tracteurs.
D'ailleurs, ce jour-là,
ils ne ramassent
que 15 mètres cubes.
-Pour l'instant,
depuis le début de la saison,
on a ramassé
à peu près 200 tonnes.
L'an dernier,
on était arrivés à 5000 tonnes.
-Et en 2021, année record,
11 000 tonnes
ont été récoltées à Hillion,
et c'est l'Etat
qui finance ce ramassage.
-Une année forte comme 2021,
ça peut représenter
1 million d'euros pour l'Etat.
Là, on met 1 million d'euros
mais on ferme nos plages,
donc on a pas résolu
le problème.
-Alors, Mickaël Cosson
aimerait bien ne plus voir
ces tracteurs sur ces plages.
-Ce sont quand même
des engins
d'assez grande importance.
Il n'y a rien de naturel à voir
un tracteur sur une plage.
On préférerait avoir
d'autres types d'engins
qui viennent pas
enlever ce sable.
Les algues transportées
sont composées de sable.
Du coup,
on est en train de dégrader
le milieu naturel,
donc il faut qu'on évolue
sur nos techniques
de ramassage,
qu'on fasse en sorte
que des zones comme celle-ci,
on ne laisse pas s'amonceler
des algues vertes,
car c'est une marée verte.
Imaginez si c'était
une marée noire.
On considérerait
qu'aujourd'hui,
on aurait ces nappes de mazout
qui viennent s'échouer,
mais on dirait de surtout pas
les ramasser en mer.
On crierait au scandale.
Cependant, c'est ce scandale
auquel on assiste.
Donc il nous faut évoluer,
faire en sorte
que ce ramassage soit fait
avant échouage
pour qu'on puisse
accéder à nos plages.
-En clair,
que ces algues
soient récoltées en mer.
Huit ans que le député
se bat pour ça.
Et ce matin,
il teste ce nouvel engin.
Cette barge un peu spéciale
est en phase d'expérimentation
depuis quatre mois.
-Ce bateau a été pensé
et construit
uniquement pour la collecte
des algues vertes.
C'est le premier en France,
certainement au monde,
qui est dédié à cela.
-Le tapis va
jusqu'à quelle profondeur ?
-Là, on va à peu près
à -50 cm dans l'eau.
On a breveté le système,
la concurrence peut arriver.
Les tapis frontaux
remontent les algues
sur 2 tapis transverses,
qui les concentrent
dans un tapis central qui déverse
dans un ou plusieurs big bags
selon les moyens
de déchargement.
-A terme,
le bateau pourrait récolter
jusqu'à 30 tonnes d'algues
par jour.
-1 tonne d'algues collectée
en dehors
de la période estivale
donnera 10 tonnes
pendant la période estivale.
L'idée est double.
C'est curatif :
l'été, on ramasse
toutes les algues qu'on trouve
pour éviter
qu'elles arrivent à terre.
Et préventif :
en amont et en aval de l'été,
on en ramasse peut-être moins,
mais il y a un facteur 10.
Ce qu'on va ramasser
en septembre
donnerait peut-être 10 tonnes
l'année prochaine
en plein mois d'août.
-Mais le ramassage en mer
a un coût :
900 000 euros d'investissement
pour l'entreprise.
Les futures sorties
seront financées par l'Etat,
qui s'est engagé sur trois ans.
-Ce principe d'appel d'offres
et d'accord-cadre de trois ans
nous a permis d'envisager
un financement
sur fonds propres.
Il y a une réalité
économique derrière.
On s'est engagés parce que
l'Etat s'est engagé derrière.
Le chantier naval est proche,
à Paimpol.
Tous les hivers,
on rentre
et on fait
les améliorations nécessaires.
-Cet engin,
quand, en 2015,
j'étais tout seul
à le réclamer,
on était pas beaucoup
à vouloir soutenir
ce type de projets,
et aujourd'hui,
les mentalités changent
au fur et à mesure.
On se rend compte que oui,
une algue échouée,
ça veut dire
qu'on a échoué.
Je suis satisfait.
On le sera encore plus
quand on pourra
aller partout
et qu'on aura obtenu
les autorisations.
-Car pour le moment,
le bateau est limité
au large.
Le fond de la baie
est une zone environnementale
protégée.
Le député le sait :
la partie n'est pas gagnée.
Elle va se jouer
à terre.
Une réunion est organisée
par le sous-préfet
aux algues vertes,
un poste unique en France
créé il y a un an et demi
pour trouver des solutions
aux marées vertes.
Cette fois, il s'agit
de rassurer
les mytiliculteurs.
La traversée du bateau
n'abîmera pas
leurs moules de bouchot.
-Le bateau qui collecte
va évidemment
faire marcher son tapis,
donc il ne faudrait pas qu'il soit
trop près des bouchots.
Donc il faut que vous visiez
le milieu de l'allée,
quitte à ce qu'il ramasse pas
toutes les algues vertes
qui sont proches des moules.
-C'est le député
qui va jouer les intermédiaires
entre cet éleveur de moules
et le responsable du bateau.
-Il faut que vous rencontriez
l'ensemble des mytiliculteurs
pour voir les modalités.
C'est le plus simple.
Là, ils sont
en pleine saison.
-Je sais pas
si vous avez l'occasion
de vous balader
dans les bouchots.
-Non.
-Vous pouvez venir avec nous.
-Oui, tout à fait.
Déjà, on va échanger
nos numéros
pour s'organiser
une petite visite.
-J'avais cette contrainte
sur les mytiliculteurs.
Je m'étais engagé
à ne pas le faire
tant qu'on voyait pas
les choses sur le bateau.
Maintenant, l'enjeu,
c'est d'élargir
à la zone mytilicole,
et puis, un jour...
-Prochain.
-...ce qu'on espère....
-Très prochain !
-...le plus vite possible,
c'est de pouvoir accéder
à la réserve.
Mais ça,
c'est dans un troisième temps.
Chaque extension
est une conquête,
mais qui est nécessaire.
On fait des choses.
-On voit bien
qu'il nous faut trouver
un consensus, un équilibre,
et savoir comment on fait
pour mettre en danger le moins
de personnes possible.
C'est là toute la difficulté.
-Merci à tous.
-Mais dans la baie,
d'autres sont plus difficiles
à convaincre.
Si les algues
prolifèrent en bord de mer,
c'est qu'elles se nourrissent
de nitrates,
qui proviennent
des fuites d'azote
des agriculteurs.
Certains ont fait des efforts,
réduit les engrais,
et depuis 40 ans,
les taux de nitrates
dans les eaux
diminuent, certes,
mais trop peu
et pas assez vite.
-Bonjour, Pierre-Yves
-Bonjour,
monsieur le député.
-Ca va.
-Oui, ça va.
-Pierre-Yves est éleveur de porcs
et de vaches laitières.
L'étiquette de pollueur
l'agace.
Depuis plusieurs années,
il a fait évoluer
ses méthodes.
-Depuis deux ans,
on a encore changé
quelques pratiques
pour encore avoir moins
de fuites d'azote.
On utilise un produit
qui s'appelle Z'fix.
On l'épand
sur les aires d'exercice ici.
Les vaches mangent ici.
Elles bousent ici.
Ca fait travailler le fumier
naturellement, sans composter.
Il travaille
naturellement.
Il évite aussi
la perte d'azote
par volatilisation.
-Mais l'Etat veut que
les agriculteurs de la région
s'engagent plus fortement.
-En tout,
il y a 75 vaches.
-L'objectif est de réduire
les flux de nitrates
dans les eaux
de 30 %.
-Ce qu'on me demande
aujourd'hui,
c'est de mettre
moins de maïs
et plus d'herbe.
Sauf que si je mets
moins de maïs
et plus d'herbe,
avec le climat
qu'on a ici,
la baie qui repousse
souvent l'eau,
il pleut à 10 km,
il pleut pas ici,
c'est sûr que demain,
je vais pas nourrir
mes 75 vaches
avec plus d'herbe
et moins de maïs.
Sur la commune,
tout le monde travaille
dans le bon sens.
Tout le monde a fait
des efforts très importants
depuis au moins 25 ans.
Je le prends mal
parce qu'à chaque fois,
on nous met ça sur le dos.
Les efforts qu'on a faits
ont été porteurs,
mais on est arrivés,
je crois...
On arrivera pas à diminuer
beaucoup plus.
-Il reste
des améliorations à faire,
mais le niveau escompté
est difficile à atteindre.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
évoluer en amont
et en aval.
Si c'est quelque chose
que vous pouvez jamais
atteindre,
on fait comment ?
On met la Bretagne
sous jachère
et on part vivre à Paris ?
-Actuellement,
les taux de nitrates
dans les cours d'eau bretons
stagnent à 30 mg par litre.
Pour diminuer de moitié
les algues vertes,
il faudrait redescendre
sous 10 mg.
Un chiffre jamais atteint
en Bretagne depuis 1976
et le début
de l'agriculture intensive.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA